today we're going to do something that
i'm very excited about which is show up
my minecraft world if i may can i
please
i just thought it could be cool to do
like a summary of what we got so far
this is the main mansion
the main biz
the my beauty
uh i wanted to have like an eastern
style to it kind of like uh i was
watching avatar when i designed it i
thought like the fire nation kind of
looked cool
there's supposed to be a planet there
but it's not loaded in and we're going
to have a lot of that issue because i
don't know after after the latest update
it's everything is laggy and i have so
much stuff going on these are my as
people i cherish and love them we will
go through them later
uh but why don't we start with the main
gist of this whole giant ass building
which is here the main hub next to dark
sven 2.0 in banquez uh so you come home
from an adventure you come home from the
nether portal which is supposed to be
over there your box is full you want to
just dump it all somewhere you don't
want to go to each of the boxes to put
them in yeah
that's boring i present to you therefore
as some of you know my famous automatic
sorting system also known as ass you can
see it's already working actually that's
cool so you can dump in any of these
chests all the stuff that you don't want
to sort out
i'm putting in different boxes just
because it's faster that way because it
shoots out faster otherwise it takes
just one at a time it doesn't really
matter uh you could also if you wanted
to dump all the stuff you have in your
red shulker box that's why these are
here so
you know if you had stuff in here
like i don't know a couple arrows just
to show
uh you could that's another method to do
it and holy cow the it's making me lag
so you'll see them get shot out here
underneath
uh why don't i just show you the insides
so here's a tick for each of the
different boxes that then shoots out
here
they all meet in the middle so it goes
through here which is the first sorting
process which is later for when they're
supposed to be melted or not i'll show
that later it's really cool actually
back to surface and if it isn't
painfully obvious i am super proud of
this build uh but anyway so items get
shot through here and they go through
this main sort of pump here which is
connected
to the west side of the building and the
east side of the building two other two
pumps uh there's a lot of pipe systems
just intertwining and connecting but
this is the main one that shoots out
uh you'll see the items pass through
here until they find their respective
box which is this one for this item and
as you can see it's filling itself up
it's pretty standard this is done into a
massive scale all of these are getting
sorted items you see them pass through
at the top
and then they also go through here
here here and then the last one is this
block so all of these type of things
will automatically sort i do have some
empty ones then if an item isn't get
recognized it ends up here it's usually
all the eggs i don't need these eggs so
i hit the flick and then it gets burned
in the lava
it is kind of annoying to listen to so
i'll just i'll just keep collecting eggs
for now so why don't we go to the west
side and start talking about all the
items there so here's what i talked
about earlier one of the main pumps it's
so fun seeing items pass through because
that means it is working even with a low
render distance i should increase it
this pump goes all the way to the bottom
underneath the building and i'll show
you later which is then connected to the
main hub that i talked about earlier it
has my pumpkin farm right here which is
amazing as you can see they get
collected underneath and then there's my
melon farm works the exact same way i
have a semi-automatic netherwart farm
which gets collected underneath here
once you farm
you see they're disappearing you can
make them kind of autumn fully automatic
but yeah i don't know since i needed so
much nether brick i i did need to make
one of these uh anyway here is my
creeper farm which i love it looks so
cool
usually automatic farms look kind of
ugly i'm not gonna lie it's not
you know my design i just kind of
changed how it looks like a little bit
so it looks like a japanese
uh pagoda basically only creepers can
spawn in these heights then there's a
water uh redstone that ticks every other
block
so that the creepers will get pushed
down into the middle i'll show you it's
the standard form i don't need to
explain how all of them work but
they fall down here they get sucked in
there they die there the items gets
collected and it goes through a pipe
underneath the surface into the pump
it's pretty cool
let's go to the
east side here we have
our pump number
i fell down the whole thing damn it
you're good
hold up let me go up again oh my god
they're killing me mind crying please
make hoppers less laggy it didn't used
to be like this i swear i have a good
computer i swear damn bunky you look
good in this light man here are my
carrot farm beet farm potato farm
they work amazingly they used to break
all the time in the past because i would
give them some freedom kind of like
free-range chickens they were allowed to
go outside but um now they're not
allowed to go outside and it works
beautifully they are great people that
work hard for me and i appreciate them
of course they're just amazing you me i
make so much money thanks to these guys
basically once their inventory is full
because they collect what uh they farm
they trade it with the guys in the
middle and the guys in the middle just
drop them underneath him and that gets
collected in the system and then gets
pumped into the system again uh it's all
fully automatic the only process that i
have to do is making uh making the trade
i redirected the all the farming stuff
here just so i can access them quicker
it's a sub ash i guess you can call it
so
uh
all the carrots and all the stuff yeah
it gets here and even the melon i i put
a long pipe that goes all the way over
here so i don't have to walk all the way
to the
thing and i can just trade them really
quickly and i can see what they are
trading you trade me beat give me my
beat money and then if i have stuff left
over i can just dump it here and it gets
shot back into the ass system
sub ash system sorry i have more
villagers down here but i realize i
don't
need them anymore
like they're kind of useless hold up
this thing at night by the way looks so
good i'll show you later more but yeah i
have more that i can trade with i just a
lot of them died
and then they're just too annoying to
keep track on i don't really need the
money anymore the lightning would keep
striking them uh but now they added the
lightning rod thank you minecraft thank
you mojang i really appreciate the
lightning round but yeah you know we're
doing we're doing good out here and
we're making money i'm
i'm proud of my minecraft wealth more
than anything
this is like my house tour cringe
youtubers there's actual house tours
real youtubers minecraft host tour
we haven't explained everything that
goes on underneath the surface so let's
go downstairs actually there's so many
amazing new minecraft youtube channels
i've basically just taken their ideas
and and copied it so i can't take credit
but yeah basically all the food gets
collected here and it goes in there and
it's so satisfying seeing them get shot
around uh it doesn't seem like they're
doing any oh it's night so they're not
trading
anyway we do also have if we head over
here it's important that this house uh
the inside was lit up well one creeper
can cause a
horrible situation
here is the underneath of my nether
farm i think
here is the underneath of my melon and
pumpkin farms my sheepskin farm so i get
all the different colors it's a great
farm automatic farm it's fully automatic
and any anything fully automatic i've
decided to build so once they cut their
skin
it gets shot out from here
which then goes into
you guessed it one of the main pumps
it's over there right there uh there's a
lot of connection here to this main pump
and i had to make some weird solutions
because i was really running low on
space
uh there's also the paper farm same same
gist of that it goes here back into you
guessed it the main pump damming pump
which is really useful i love automatic
farms i don't know what it is something
just watching stuff work on its own it's
so satisfying
i love it i don't know if you can tell
next up we have one of my pride and joys
my giga ass melter this thing is a guy
damn beast i love this thing so the way
it works is
these uh two mine carts collects from
this chest what needs to be melted which
then gets distributed underneath into
the furnaces here the furnaces then get
fuel
from all of these
farms of bamboo that just have detectors
that crushes them and then gets
collected underneath i built way too
many of these that was not necessary at
all to build that many because
[Laughter]
they're all full they're all full the
thing was like when i tested it i needed
more and more and more but clearly like
they start accumulating if you're not
melting anything so oh this one's empty
that's probably got stuck somewhere
great or maybe i actually just gave up
it doesn't matter because it gets
distributed throughout anyway but yeah
these minecarts collects the
the fuel and it all automatically puts
in coal as well if it runs out so right
now it's melting some raw iron
which once it's done it spits out
as you can see here and it goes back
into the pump which then
shoves it back into the system and then
into my
my chest the way the back end works is
over here these are uh this is a sub
sorting ass
where they go over here and if they fit
any of these
uh throughout here then they will be
caught up by the system and they'll
shoot them out down into here and
they'll say okay we're ready to be
melted
these hoppers will pick them up
see how fast that was 60 blocks
uh it will then
distribute them to the smelters which is
melting the look how fast it's doing all
this i love it it's already spitting out
it's so satisfying to watch it i need to
cover up with some more glass though
let's go up and check them and they
should be adding up here
yeah they are
i am so rich you are all poor i am so
rich
it's so satisfying
i love it
a millionaire laughs at his money yes
yes
bring me wealth
i could sit here all day just looking at
that yes
yes do go
oh yes
yes make me richer
so it is quite fast it's a well-oiled
system isn't that right bonky
[Music]
um
you know we also have other stuff but
i'm not sure if it's that interesting
this is one of the first things i built
you guys saw it on the live streams
i think i'll make it probably into like
a bee farm or a honey farm
uh because i know i can make that fully
automatic as well oh speaking of the
iron by the way i don't know if i showed
this is my iron melter so if you look
underneath there are villagers who are
scared of the zombie which spawns a
golem iron golem
this thing works
chef kiss so well i don't know how this
is not an original design to me but i
mean i did kind of make it you know it
just works so well i it's like me
stealing the ideas of other people and
then making into something even more
amazing because it works so good
it never get he used to get stuck all
the time he never gets stuck anymore
thanks to new and improved systems so
good uh so he burns up uh which then
sends over all the iron which gets
through this pipe underneath the water
so cool right then goes to that pump
that pump goes there and then all the
way through the air system and um
yeah
this is the nerdiest video ever isn't it
oh i'm sorry are you dying again oh
that's too bad
god it's so satisfying
hey i'm not saying this is the most
ethical morally ethical build in the
world okay yes we are profiting from the
suffering of other people this is not
clean energy that provides but look
we're getting rich from it it's all
worth it i share my will uh let's go
upstairs this is my living quarters
we got
donkey not bonky uh my alchemy
place this is where i sleep definitely
have neglected this area like it needs
if i were to do more stuff it'd probably
be here but you know it's got some
stuff on it
i think we've got more glass melting oh
it's the melted glass being shot back
oh that's fun
that's fun yes it is let's jump down
i know mojang is not gonna do it but i
would love
if they made a new sort of redstone
machine
something like this
if for example i have a sugarcane farm i
would love to have some sort of redstone
minecraft contraption the redstone that
makes automatically this like turns any
item in the box into the thing
they're never gonna do that it makes no
sense for them to do that because then
you could make it so that oh okay add
the gunpowder add the paper
and then it automatically makes the
rocket for you i just think that would
be really cool but you know i'm probably
in the 0.00
percent of people who gives a [ __ ]
oh looks like i got some more stuff i'll
just dump it in here it'll take care of
itself isn't that right dark sven i want
to lastly show you guys how it looks
like at night because i i'm so proud of
it but meanwhile when it gets dark we
can head over here there's my uh
creeper disc farm it doesn't matter over
here is my
uh what is it what is it called oh raid
farm and over here is my pillager
building i was lucky it was so close to
me
uh it actually looks kind of cool at
night not gonna lie
it's really fun too just seeing them
since i built it in glass just seeing
them get sucked up through the machinery
uh so all the pillagers spawn because
there used to be a pillager tower down
there uh they go to attack the iron
whatever they call but lo and behold
they get sucked we'll see them get
sucked up any minute now
there you are
come get sucked my dudes yes
yes
and you can just kill them one shot one
kill
i mean the best xp is just trading to be
honest and i have a cow up here in case
i don't want to get the buff this is
very
very satisfying then once you have the
raid buff you just fly down here get the
buff
from downstairs
fly back home do the trading bada bing
bada boom you're rich baby oh look now
you see all the planets
i could build it a little higher now
because of the new update which i really
appreciate thank you mojang
very cool
uh here is another area
i tried experimenting with shooting
items from the nether into
uh
my ass
but uh
the chunk needs to be loaded and uh i
know there's coding ways to cheat that
but uh i'm not smart enough and it feels
like cheating a little bit
here is my nether base it's kind of
bland there's not much to it it's
apparently not safe either i don't know
how these people spawn
oh because i don't have it carpeted is
that way
um but yeah these tunnels go either way
and they're quite i i love the design i
got on them like they're very satisfying
to run in so this one goes right over
there which goes to my nether castle
this is cozy
nether used to be so scary when you were
starting off but now bro
we control this city
i own this town
uh you can leave if you want to and
there are some other passageways and i
don't need to go through all of them but
yeah pretty cool
it's getting dark nice
that's just what i wanted so yeah thank
you for watching my
tour of my minecraft world i'm very
proud and i love this thing
i me now finally get to show it and at
its peak when it's dark yes
holy moly i added lava around which is
something i wanted to do for a long time
but i just felt like it's too dangerous
let's fly up
yeah baby
yeah
[Music]
boom baby let's go gotta make sure not
to fly into the llama
let's go on top of the planet
[Music]
damn
i'm so stoked oh [ __ ] yeah
all right guys thanks for letting me do
this tour i appreciate it i love this
stuff
uh
i think i'm done
i just need to add some small details
but overall i'm
i'm done man thanks for watching leave a
like bro fist